[yells]
A gymnast would always notice
if a screw or a nail were on the beam,
'cause you're pretty much always
spotting where your hands and feet are.
Hi, everyone. I'm Katelyn Ohashi,
a four-time national team member
and a former UCLA gymnast.
So, I just started my own YouTube channel,
so you guys can check me out there.
Today, I'm going to be
watching gymnastics movie clips
and rating them on their accuracy.
I like that they added
not only flipping skills,
but connecting skills,
'cause you need both for gymnastics.
So, she did a roundoff back handspring,
two and a half, punch front full.
I used to do that skill
in my routine as well.
The leaps are not necessarily
what you would see.
I've always thought the
kicking parts were funny to me.
Typically, if you're an elite gymnast
you're so tired that you don't even
have time to add those things.
I do a double lay like that.
We both have that part
in common, for sure.
In 2006, I feel like gymnasts were
more robotic than this movie portrayed,
which is super awesome.
So this type of routine
is way more accepted now
than it used to be.
[laughing] I don't think I've ever seen
anyone do that in gymnastics,
but it's incredible
and would be super fun.
The dance moves are way different
than something you would see on beam.
I don't know if I've ever seen someone
do a back handspring double back
just because there's not a lot of momentum
out of a step-out back handspring.
This was definitely less realistic
gymnastics-wise as
well, besides the dance,
just because it was like,
she definitely didn't have
all the requirements in there.
She didn't have a leap pass or turn,
unless you want to count the head spin,
'cause I would.
I would say she would just need
more dance elements,
even though she was
dancing the whole time,
but specific dance elements.
So, I would give the
first one a 10 out of 10
and the second one probably a 3 out of 10.
OK, so I've never cheered before, so what?
Front handspring, step out,
roundoff, back handspring,
step out, roundoff, back handspring,
full twisting layout.
Every gymnast would
probably be able to do that,
but it's not anything our coaches
would ever ask us to do.
She started out with, like, a cartwheel,
and then she turned around
and did a front handspring.
We never have cartwheels
in our tumbling passes.
It'll be roundoffs, which is
the closest thing to that.
You typically will turn
when you're in the air
or not on your feet.
Also she only took, like,
two steps into that,
which I understand some of
her skills built momentum,
but we do a little more than two steps.
Probably at least three or four.
It's a lot harder on a hardwood floor.
We do have a little padding
and a little bit of a spring.
Props to cheerleaders,
because they do a lot
of stuff that I'm like,
I have no idea how they did it.
So, for an accurate gymnastics pass,
that would probably be a zero.
Amazing. [laughs]
So, that was rhythmic gymnastics
and not artistic gymnastics.
I'm not too knowledgeable
on rhythmic gymnastics,
but obviously it's always on the floor,
they're incredibly flexible,
they're coordinated,
which, most gymnasts,
artistic gymnastics are not coordinated.
So, they take that ribbon,
and they throw it up,
they do something beautiful,
and then they catch it again.
You know, he was getting pretty
good spins on his ribbon,
but since rhythmic gymnastics
is so beautiful and stunning,
he didn't elongate his legs at all,
and he wasn't showing any flexibility.
He was, like, galloping,
versus actually doing something.
I've never seen a gymnast
smoking on the rings.
Women don't do rings as an apparatus.
That's a men's event.
And typically you would
see them straight out.
He was kind of down here,
which would be even harder to hold.
Just thinking about it,
I'm like, oh, his shoulders
are torn. [laughs]
And his chest, everything.
Iron cross is near to impossible
unless you're, like, that trained in it.
I'm gonna rate that probably a zero.
[yells]
A gymnast would always notice
if a screw or a nail were on the beam,
'cause you're pretty much always spotting
where your hands and feet are,
and you're also just looking at the beam.
Coach: Here we go, Candice. Stay loose.
[yells]
[Katelyn laughs]
That girl on bars was
doing a lot of giants,
and she needed to come off the bar
a lot sooner than that anyways.
The form, the giants were fine.
She did a little blind change in there.
Also, I think that if a lot of chalk
is coming into your face,
you would be able to close your eyes
and stop the momentum of your giant
and just kind of jump off after
instead of doing the
whole extra peeling thing.
I think that it's goofy for the most part,
but it's more common than you'd think.
Like, a lot of people --
we call it scorpion.
So I've ended up like that a couple times
from that height of that bar,
and it looks painful,
and it is painful.
So, this is obviously a
little bit exaggerated,
but gymnastics is definitely
a very dangerous sport,
and I know of people that have actually
lost their lives to the sport.
And so it's something that
you can't really let
your mind get loose in
no matter how comfortable
you are with a skill
or how long you've been doing it.
Granted, we learn how to
fall from a young age.
So a lot of our falls are safer,
but you can still get into
stuff you didn't expect.
What she was doing on bars,
it's not that hard to stop your momentum.
She should have been a little
more prepared to stop them.
I would give the gymnastics a 10.
Obviously I think that fall is
very realistic in gymnastics,
but how it happened is not realistic.
Spider-Man: Oh, boy.
I would say it was a little bit more
like cheerleading back handsprings,
which, there's a very clear difference
between a cheerleader and gymnast.
Cheerleaders have more bent knees,
and Spider-Man definitely
had more bent knees.
He was lower to the ground when he landed.
Gymnastics is just very technical,
so if we were to have bent
knees in our back handsprings,
we would get deductions.
He was just trying to
do the back handsprings
and get out of the way,
which I totally understand.
It reminds me of this one girl,
Danusia Francis, who used to go to UCLA,
but she was about to fall
out of one of her tumbling passes,
and instead of stepping or falling,
she decided to do a back handspring,
and it kind of looked like Spider-Man's.
I've always thought about, like,
what would I do in a fight?
Would I be able to throw
out some gymnastics moves
and somehow hit them or dodge? [laughs]
So, I don't know if anything
would really be that helpful.
Maybe being able to kick high.
'Cause I'm short, so I need
all the height I can get.
We'll say an 8. We'll say an 8.
She did an Arabian.
That's what she did when she turned.
And you would want to land
completely facing backwards,
and then turn in the air
and do a front flip to her
little handstand thing she did.
She got good height on it.
I think her form was pretty good.
Yeah, everything looked really clean.
Her knees were straight,
it looked like she had momentum
on her back handsprings for the most part.
And she did enough to build that momentum
to be able to get that
height for the Arabian.
We used to have to hold handstands
for a minute without moving.
I'm sure people could
do it longer than that.
Especially if you're walking,
you can hold it for a long time,
but minimum a minute.
I would rate this a 9.
She was actually pretty
good at gymnastics.
Up here!
Kelly, no!
That actually reminded me
of gymnastics in the '70s,
because we used to have bars
that were way closer together,
so you would hit your hips on the bar.
That's how close they were.
I'm very grateful for the change,
because I feel like they definitely
always walked around with
bruises on their hips
and their pelvic bones.
But gymnastics also got more difficult
when they spread the bars out wider,
because then you were
able to do more skills,
release moves, certain stuff like that.
I've kicked my coach on bars.
And I also know of just
people getting injured
all the time from walking underneath.
Could it kick over a dinosaur?
If you had the intentions, maybe.
That was a metal bar, right?
And those don't give as much.
But ours is wood.
You don't use your muscles on bars.
Except for holding,
your forearms and stuff like that.
You want to use the bar as much
to your own benefit as you can.
Gymnastically, since it came out in '97,
I'll rate it a
7.
I don't think the leaps were that good.
You know, some gymnasts
don't have great leaps.
Technically for choreography
there aren't points,
but I think it only helps
if you can take the judge
out of their head so much
and want to just watch you
so they're not constantly
just writing down deductions.
Ariana: Focus.
Two flips with a full twist,
push off right leg,
and then tumble through the roundoff.
What I actually really
enjoy about that movie
is that it goes into her thought process
when she's about to tumble,
and I think that most gymnasts have cues
that they give themselves
every single time that they go.
And so hers was like,
"Push off your back leg,"
"strong," certain stuff like that.
So it's these little reminders
that just help us get through the pass
and stay focused.
So, I actually think that
I've competed in that leo.
Some leotards that I was wearing,
the elastic would be worn out,
and that's when we'd have to get the spray
and use it to stick our leos down.
We'll give it, we'll give it a 10.
I know, I'm not biased
or anything. [laughs]
She definitely had leg separation
on her path to the low bar.
She also, if you want
to get really technical,
she didn't hit her handstands.
The bars were much closer in the '70s
than that clip showed.
For the '70s, I would say that was
very accurate for the skill level,
besides the bars being
a different length away from each other.
That isn't that common
to see that dismount,
but it does still exist today.
It's just pretty rare,
and you would see it
more through that period,
but everything was kind of the same.
Like, all those skills
you still see today.
She definitely had deductions
within her routine.
When she landed, she
obviously stumbled around.
And she did have a release move.
But you'll see multiple release
moves and spinning moves
if you're trying to go to the Olympics.
I'm giving that a 10 for accuracy
just because of the way
the coach responded.
[laughs]
It's funny because that was in Russia,
and I had Russian coaches,
and I would say Russian coaches
tend to be pretty brutal. [laughs]
And a lot of coaches are,
so if we just look at
each other, we're like,
"Oh, yeah, our coach is
Russian," we're like,
ah, we understand exactly
how training was, then.
I thought it was a 10, because you still
see all of those skills today.
[crowd cheering]
So, she does the hands,
her feet go over,
and then she does an extra flip
and lands back on her feet.
That first one is very accurate.
So, in college we would have a natty stick
and a college stick.
The college stick is more
acting like you stuck it.
Like, if you know you're gonna step,
it's like stepping and
just saluting to the judges
immediately, and that's
more of a college stick.
Whereas a natty stick is
being able to hold it,
put your feet together, salute,
and then turn and salute the judges.
[crowd cheering]
I have no idea what that second vault was,
because it didn't even look
like she flipped in it.
It just looked like she was twisting.
And so I flinch, 'cause
I'm like, wait a minute,
is she supposed to now do a flip?
The second one,
it would probably be worth nothing.
[laughs] She didn't flip.
That's actually based on a true story.
Kerri Strug, who went to the Olympics
and broke her foot.
She had to go again,
and she stuck on one leg.
So, my freshman year,
I was competing on beam,
I finished the routine,
but when I did my dismount,
my foot slipped off and
I landed on my head.
What I didn't know is
I fractured my sternum.
I'm getting tested for a concussion,
and they told me that there
was "equipment malfunction,"
so I got to go again.
And I remember doing a skill on the floor
before I went again, and I was like,
oh, wow, my chest really hurts.
But I still did the full beam routine,
did the dismount again, got home,
found out that I had fractured my sternum.
[laughs]
So, I would rate the first clip a 10,
and then the second
clip, I'll rate it a 4.
I feel like I'm definitely doing
really bad on these ratings.
I'm, like, going up.
But this is how it goes.
So, in gymnastics too,
the later you go in the lineup,
the higher score you're
probably gonna get.